okay four people joining our livestream
here a third live streamed meeting of
the day we are continuing our discussion
about how to represent annotations in
most language and Carlo you have this
this is the functions that exist for
graphs with properties is that correct
correct and the other one most of them
are implemented for audio annotations
and some of them have been discussed and
discussed like the annotated upper okay
but this here set property is is what we
were discussing is annotated correct yes
yes I'm not sure a conclusion has been
reached on what is the proper name but
yes in the Emporium ployment ation it is
called audio annotate okay all right um
just a minute I just want to record this
okay alright so now what what are we
looking at here so this is vertex labels
is that Charles as this this is what it
does right now is that correct
there is the current behavior of the
Garcias okay and so this would become
instead of saying property value this
would now become annotation value yes
okay so this is now example detail we
would say annotate that so this would
just be annotate correct
mm-hm it might be so safer to just go
with object annotate specific ones and
then later on merge them if possible
I don't know how universal we want to
make it at the get-go well what are the
specific annotates are there so at the
moment we have audio annotate and I'm
not sure if image annotator is already
existing but that was the plan I don't I
think we need better use cases before we
roll out image annotations really we
need to use it ourselves it's too early
if it roll it out it's gonna be wrong
we're gonna have to fix it
there's a little inconvenience everybody
but I think we it can go for 12:1 you
know as long as we focus on building up
good use cases but are you interested in
other instances of object annotate or
what kinds of things we merge that's
been there for a while the mesh works
exactly like graph ok you know so
boundary mesh region mesh region they
support the same level of of properties
/ annotations graph does I don't see any
special value to have you know annotate
or Joe graph annotate right because I
you know second argument is hopefully
the same byte tag where on what so the
additional value that we have in audio
for the annotate is that we can compute
automatically annotations from the
content of the signal I see so in other
words you would say
with Graff okay so Charles the analog of
that would be for example for a graph
layout you could explicitly spray
coordinates for the embedding into the
graph am I making sense what yes but so
what happens right now which you don't
think you have the functionality for is
what we would say then is something like
I mean again I don't know um you know
annotate a graph , you know vertex
coordinates let's say okay and that
would mean if we did it that way that
would mean go and try and automatically
figure out what those vertex coordinates
are and insert those annotations into
the graph so that's done anyways what
anyways we just delete on do that at the
right time for efficiency okay fine but
let's imagine that I wanted to spray
those annotations into the graph because
I'm gonna process them in some way for
example well maybe it's a different
annotation which is not I think
something so there's standard properties
or standard annotations which there's
quite a few for graph and mesh you have
to do with steric styles and labels
shapes or in our coordinates mm-hmm yeah
okay fine but I mean I'm saying what
what caller is saying is an audio
annotate no I get it I know you can say
audio comma speakers for example and it
will automatically annotate speakers
everywhere
right but more commonly I kind of think
that we will have functions that do that
rather than we don't because
it's a significant thing to identify
speakers it's not an insignificant thing
yeah yeah yeah right you know and well
so you're saying that it won't
necessarily be the word annotate I think
it might be something else and what it
does it takes your audio and produces
annotated audio out with speakers
annotated and we might be a more rich
away to return values and that gives us
kind of better workflows
okay well so the next question would be
is annotate the right name for the
general thing the only thing I don't
like here particularly go ahead what
people can say well obviously personally
forgot it doesn't seem to merge that
well annotated notation because for some
property like weight capacity or salt is
not a sanitation yeah I know but this
property isn't right either so what do
we want that is okay so is there
something we can come up with that is
neither annotation nor property
attribute would have been perfect okay
well let's write down some of these
words attribute which we can't use it's
not meta information hits some they're
words like gloss which nobody will
understand did you say gloss gloss yes
yeah I don't understand that it's
understanding um I mean that's like the
footnote type thing
in based mark on what mark yeah that's
actually another thing that's used in
some areas disjoint area so for instance
point processes when you want to have
additional properties on points they're
called marks and in PDE solving you know
when you want to mark you'd if you mark
your different boundary conditions
differently because different things are
going to apply to them
they're also called marks so mark is
another quote about extra
you
I mean see the problem is it wants to be
something generic it is it is it's not
really a property in the case of
something like this Audio annotation
it's hardly you know it's not it's it's
something that kind of floats above the
actual thing itself um I mean the
problem is that you know the word that
you want depends on how high above
you're floating
exactly what I was gonna say I think
that there's a whole span of it okay so
the things that Charles brought up we'd
wait like a weighted graph feels very
fundamental we unified it so we have a
single object that deals weird
multigraphs weighted graphs
let's write down some of these things
okay types of quotes annotation okay
so weights in a graph you know colors of
vertices okay so yeah very differently
we have things like who is speaking here
what animal is this is this region in a
picture
okay so um okay what are some other
examples where the coordinate where a
vertex is placed there plenty of more
examples for graph so capacity
so there's weights there's capacities
yeah okay okay I'm looking for ones that
are more you know add-ons if you
understand what I'm saying
I understand there are ones that are
quite fundamental there are also ones
that are add-ons and for meshes can we
describe that for also for meshes so for
meshes it's a little simpler most of the
properties there have to do with styles
and labels okay
I mean there's also the marker right
like you pointed out earlier where the
mark is so that gives you basically kind
of like a color or a label in the sense
of like one two three that tells you
this collection of boundary regions a
boundary elements gonna have the
following constraint on it that's how
it's used operationally this collection
why is it called a mark that's the
tradition there
okay so it's it's a way to to give tags
if you like to subsets of boundary
Regents a boundary yeah okay so there's
basically tagging is another there's
another type of thing
tagging eg to associate related pieces
of a mesh or something right
but I'm guessing you're also after
things like high curvature low curvature
regions of a mesh right that is really
something that needs computations we
don't know but but you could imagine
that but no it's not okay all right so
what about in a notebook do we think
we're going to have these things in
notebooks as well and what would these
be in num I mean for things that have an
appearance in a notebook we're using
style am I making sense so the
precedence of things like style we've
got things like labeled which might turn
into one of these kinds of annotations
is that true or is that not true like
for example in a graph can you use
labeled yes and what does it do does it
turn into something that is vertex
labels
yes to whatever yes okay if you open the
page for the term additional card is the
list of them about seven by two type
annotation on labels
these things here yes so provide an
annotation is this other weird version
of annotation right yes okay so now what
do these become do these become
something else so do they stay as they
are difference so if we go down the list
we can work or wait this is a bug in
version and the version 12 thing that
these don't paste at the right size did
that get reported who is being him I am
Steven I'm taking a screenshot who was
that the wrong size or did it just
scroll when it pasted no it was the
wrong size it was the size it was the
source size rather than resizing for the
destination notebook I've seen this
multiple times before I've reported at
least twice so Steven if you go down
that list yeah button event handler
hyperlink pop-up window status area in
tooltip effectively go out as wrappers
in the resulting graphics rendering of
it okay so there's processing basically
that's done yes style labeled go into
more fundamental places okay all right
so they burrow into the actual data
structure yes okay
and again annotation just sits there as
if you know go out into resulting
rendering graphics so just sits there
okay
so and is there is there an l-value
nonsense going on here or not yes and
that's crucial or or or do you want to
design slow things that's you know I
don't but I don't but that's semantics
is just not it just doesn't make sense
it just so one day we need a long
psychological session with you and
discuss your phobia about L values you
know it's because they're a mess because
they involve having I mean the how do
you do it you say property of Groff
comma something property value of what
of a being a graph yeah a indirectly
references a graph so if a is equal to B
is equal to C is equal to a graph what
happens what if a equals B equals C
equals a graph what happens this being
an L value is no different from list L
values there's no what what happens in
this case then this case is you know the
reference is on a so only a change not B
or C okay so we preserved in the
complete invisibility okay all right so
all right in our vacation here there
would be property value or annotation
value a comma where equals Val okay and
you're proposing that that works for
audio as well I think that would be good
yeah first implementation then we
changed it to not have that but the
critical thing that we got for graphs
and other things is that allows us to
get real-time for instance algorithm and
you know animations and things and
objects so you know what one thing you
learned with big objects don't so the
algorithm animation code works by having
dynamic on the a yes yeah exactly
well that's reasonable enough and it
it's really slick and very cool okay all
right
okay fair enough okay so let's let's
keep going discussing what this should
be called so we need a neutral name that
is not I agree that annotation seems to
floating above properties seems too much
inside the thing so how do we how do we
make it neutral with respect to that
what's that characteristics that's too
long but also a little low maybe let's
see that's way too complicated
yeah trait hmm very
logical or
computer science II what does it mean in
computer science type systems what is it
it's it generally represents a class of
interfaces or behaviors that can be
attached to a type okay I think it's way
too elaborate
um tag we've got too many things called
tag already and tag suggests that
doesn't do anything under traits
it says characteristic attribute feature
quality property those are sort of
synonyms but it's funny that we hit them
just about all of them yes
all right but we do have a set of
functions around feature too yes okay
see what I like like for example a name
like Association has worked very well
for us it's nice and neutral and it
describes what it is what is this thing
don't say it associate stuff for things
but what is this thing really
so what we're making is the object that
is annotated becomes richer and has more
information about itself inside itself
maybe details that's what I was just
going to say details or local metadata
so then you're gonna be detailing
something when you add it obviously
ridiculous no I mean it is what
detailing means typically you know it's
I admit that it has a weird weird card
kind of um
okay let's let's let's see how these
other words would work here okay so see
unfortunately this would be details by
the way we've got a bunch of background
noise could we cut it out a bit good um
how would it work for the sum
detail is a noun well let's see what
would happen here
with something like add detail for the
set property thing blah
okay what what are they what are the
analogs here this would be
details as the our log of properties yes
properties or property value details I
think will be that's that's the analog
of properties
I think
what does property value do again so
property and detail properties and
details
we answered it no it's singular or
plural I really love let's write down
what each of these things is okay so so
here we've got let's write it down in
terms of annotation which we understand
okay so let's first of all we wrote
write down cases right which are okay so
we've got a notated of thing comma
[Music]
annotation right that's well thing comma
a annotate an annotation that's in place
annotated object right
okay next case we've got a notations
of a thing of what
well you want to call it of the whole
object oh oh it's the option isn't it
are you talking about it's an option
yeah it's an option so I'm sorry I I
wrote down what currently we have
implemented annotations is what you
called annotation rules it is meant to
be let's call it that sorry about
darkness and we're not confuse yes
definitely okay okay
okay now what now we have the next thing
which is annotate which is an object
with but this really should be called an
element here annotate an object with an
annotation right yes
I mean that's what then we'll go to the
annotation fools
set set an annotation don't do it where
what don't you need where and it we're
clear everywhere our arrow annotation
basically set an annotation from the
outside right and that's and just to
write down what the analogues of these
are so this is the equivalent of
annotations of the equivalent of
property is that right this okay
annotation rules what's that they call
it of properties like these which is an
option yes weird okay annotate is the
equivalent of set property place okay
and we've also got a few of these other
ones like hum annotation delete now
we've got foundation value annotation
value of an
and we're right which returns an
annotation correct and if you don't
specify the word after also limitations
no no that should be what what that it's
object we're actually should be do where
and and come at what about two different
things one is the no there's no setting
that and then you've got you've got the
set property this is the setting of
property value this is set property and
this then has the the additional form of
property value blah blah blah equals
right correct
but property value evaluate e2 attorney
the walks he gives you the actual value
of the what yes that's right that's what
we're saying here what are you
complaining about here this is saying
the object and we're and it gives you
the what what makes sense Charles right
okay all right what is property list
that is get what does that do that gives
you all annotations right yes notations
they're an object otherwise known as
property list okay all right so these
are our cases um so this
is for many things like an audio images
etc the word annotation is just fine and
these parts of speech work fine and so
on okay so the issue is what are some
cases where we think it works least well
okay an annotation in a graph I think
the color of a vertex arguably could be
an annotation but color in not the
actual sense of color but just as a as a
mark
I mean something like the weight of a
vertex does not seem like a very good
annotation okay so let's list bad cases
okay bad examples okay so weight of an
edge doesn't seem like an adaptation
it seems more fundamental to the graph
on the making sense yes no yes
okay what's another example of a bad
example or is this the only bad example
well for [ __ ] off you have weight
capacity weight coordinate right
I mean decide I think the label style
actually the one which are coming from
the hopper which I do coffee to water I
lost I got distracted by something could
you repeat that sorry I say [ __ ] off you
have weight capacity for example or
coordinate which are really okay weight
capacity and coordinate for example okay
so how are those represented in a graph
ultimately they like the weights for
instance you can give them as
annotations but then how are they
actually inserted in the ground I mean
why isn't it you know something like why
don't we have just like we have weighted
data why don't we have weighted edge or
or even weighted data itself I mean for
because for the graph you is he kind of
a global team and if they do cough at
once so you don't really want to wait
the individual no no I understand that
but but Charles what I'm saying is I
don't think it's right do you know we've
got plenty of other things in this list
that do not genera size themselves do
you get what I'm saying yes so we could
imagine for these cases having something
which I actually think will be an
improvement anyway which is some
explicit way of specifying weighting one
could imagine that I agree um
we don't have it I mean you have it in a
sense of generically with properties you
can still do it yeah obviously make it
simpler yeah right right but I'm saying
that that could be the form just like
some of these other things you know
store themselves that way this could be
the canonical form or even or even I
don't care which one is the canonical
form that's up to you
right but um I also think that yeah okay
so so let me just understand what some
of these other things what would this be
the right construct weighted edge or is
it the case that really we want to
consider a wrapper just called weighted
that's very generic all of a sudden I
know it is but I mean like weighted data
is I mean the advantage that you don't
want weighted edge I mean all we have
with it edge weighted vertex right
informational have with itself we did
something yeah I mean whereas weighted
could consume it so right now weighted
data um how does this correspond to what
we're talking about here the concept
that we're talking about here this is in
a way kind of a list with annotations in
a way you could can almost see it like
that
yes no because it then has weights for
all the data right the different
interpretations of what weights means
what weight means in different contexts
right but if it's just thought of as an
annotation I mean does this work no
should it I don't think so because you
don't know what the weighting of the
things that don't have um right if the
weights are useful as a relative thing
um right so you're saying everybody has
to be weighted or it doesn't make sense
correct that's all the cases I know too
I don't know of anything where you can
probably come up with some case where
you know there's a default I mean it's
like an around where there's something
where much of the data has plus/minus
but some of it doesn't maybe we have
some weights where it isn't you know
required to be universal but for what
for labels okay listen
what I'm my my tentative conclusion is
that annotation is the right name and
that we should deal with these cases
where it doesn't fit separately
um
I have the impression that everything
anything which is mathematical or that
it affects the behavior of atiek object
itself doesn't play very nicely with
Annotated I know but what's an example
of that
I thought the things were primarily
talking about here and then we're
talking about the rendering color of the
texts and things which is not of that
type right the case where it makes a
difference is this weighting stuff which
has been shoehorn in I think well I'm
trying to generalize to other cases and
I think it still mathematical nature of
things that doesn't play nicely with
right but so are there other cases where
we want a sort of mathematical notion of
annotation or it is annotation more like
styling I think that there is this
spectrum of things being close I think
that also what we've noticed that seem
to be a progression in various domains
and fields of things starting out to be
slightly far afield and then it might
sort of move closer and becomes a more
tightly integrated object over time
example um so I'm thinking of you know
so if you do you know what what point
patterns are from statistic mechanics in
a location of gas molecules let's say
what do you mean by I've heard of what
what no I thought they what are you
talking about [ __ ] patterns or or point
collections so you're studying the
distribution of these you know point
patterns yeah okay now and they can be
location of trees location of stars
location that's that that's what spatial
statistics is where I've heard of that
yes
okay now clearly like say that it's
location of trees there are other
attributes that are important to know
depending on what you want to do so for
instance for tree I've learned that
diameter at breast height is a really
important thing species is a really
important thing and then there's a
progression or more now dead or alive
yes well that better might be good for
you you know if you're doing yeah
resource inventory okay now you know so
you can view that that's just sort of
extra data but
for some things it's kind of key clearly
and then there is a there is a notion of
marked point processes where you kind of
model these extra values in addition and
also they have distributions on their
own terms thanks edenia you have to
model them in a coupled way so they can
go from being kind of little far afield
to moving closer to the object and you
have a more a more comprehensive model
that takes that into account
I understand so what you're saying is I
mean to paraphrase that what you're
saying is at the beginning you're just
saying what's the distribution of trees
later you want to say but I care whether
they're oak trees or not right but I
kind of think that we'll see that kind
of progression with other objects in the
system you know so maybe actually Roger
one way to characterize that is the
following things like is it an oak tree
or not that the question is what is
computable like the position you know
there's a there's a good kind of
calculus of positions and there's a good
theory of sort of spatial distribution
and so on there may not be such a
meaningful theory like like for example
let's say that in an extreme case let's
say we've got a characterization of the
shape of the tree which right now there
isn't a good way to characterize you
know there are some weird allama tree
parameters and so on but but imagine
that you could characterize the shape of
the tree right once you know go ahead
exactly so in that particular case I
happen to have read something about
forestry yeah things you do but anyways
that there is quite a few is actually
not that many and people actually do it
to do forest inventory or resource
inventories large scale so it's it's
kind of a well-known well-established
thing what is the the additional
parameters that you kind of measure all
right okay fair enough
yes but I kind of think that that's a
progression that you get so there's a
question you know so we designed a graph
a network subsystem so anything that's
just pure connectivity is graph anything
beyond that to sort of network
we designed it to be a multi objective
system you know because I know on the
order of 150 or so diagrammatic
languages graph like languages like
molecule for instance or right oh you
know but then you know can you in fact
build and prototype and use that in the
system and when do you decide it it's a
new object when do you decide right but
what we've done with molecule just like
with net graph is that inside their
graphs but they have additional
decoration right right and that's kind
of how it was designed for it that's
what we designed to be able to do that
kind of thing you can first start out
having your point is are we using
generic decorators or are we using
specific decorators like for molecules
of specific decorators right you know if
a system modeler what is what a notice
is something called it's another system
the connectivity semantics the edge
semantics is very complicated for what
it takes to connect system models um so
there we are we using graph to represent
that we are at some level no we're not
the graph that we have but yes we are
using graphs into internally in system
modelers okay so your point is that we
want something that is a bland way to
connect things to elements of our
structures like graphs for example yes
and that then you know so that should be
as meaningless as possible a term which
is what we've concluded right that that
should be a meaningless term and if you
want it to actually mean something like
for example in the waiting case for
instance one might need to promote that
to you know a notion of a you know
ultimately we could even imagine a
weighted graph although I don't think we
want to do it that way we have a
weighted graph but we decided to you
know it's it's part of graph okay if it
has weights it's a weighted graph fine I
mean although we decided planar graph
will be its own separate top level head
wrapper because who decided that
dr. eugenie this is just a constructor
yes got an object fair enough okay fine
um okay but but so so what we're looking
for so first of all let me just confirm
this design we are basically happy with
is that true we're still looking for a
name but we're basically happy with the
design is that a true statement from
everybody I have to say I think we can
live with annotation I you know let's
let's give it another push for a minute
but but let's just check that we're
happy with the design I I haven't really
paid attention to all this tags and so
on stuff has that been thought through
now so that seems to what we had
discussed for audio it seems to be the
same for graph as well no we should
probably discuss that later on I mean we
don't have that essentially this is a
whole query system you add know the tags
not not the query system the query
system has not been discussed but the
fact that we use tags goes to where goes
to what right that is a common but I
guess what we call the custom property
right it's correct it's a user created
property as opposed to a system one
which is just done with an option name
in the case of golf correct yes okay by
the way we we call them we did the way
we we said that their standard versus
you know custom well that's fine but
that one of them is a string tag and the
other is a symbol name correct exact
okay seems okay to me now with respect
to this annotation propagation stuff
which you've not yet addressed in graph
right we are addressing that here it is
kind of addressing the graph actually I
think the house will speak to it but I
think this situation is well addressed
what is coming from 12 might also be
discussed during that's the subgraph
stuff the the propagation of the
annotation to sub graphs and things is
that right among other things yes yes
I'll just do the same idea we you know
you know what you're here right
okay um all right we are of course right
now that's one more try here and I'm not
happy with this name I think it's it's
it's a long word it's rather it I mean I
agree with Roger it's not terrible but I
think we might be able to do better um
all right let's try other kinds of
things adjunct blah
you
so I would say of all those ones aren't
Asians is the least obscure yes so it
has that advantage going I agree
lack of obscurity is important um I'm a
live stream someone suggested layer
which won't make it but it's that is
indeed a related concept well fair
enough why don't we go ahead and start
implementing and why don't you work
through with Charles what will be needed
to update graph to be able to use
annotation now we've we've still got
this strange thing called annotation
that's out there that means something
completely different which I think we
should deprecated right we're not we're
not walking on top of that syntax and we
won't but I don't think I think that
that particular thing what were we going
to call that the current thing that's
called on it so I'm all for that we work
through we know what the dist what the
implementation is but I don't think we
need to make it a requirement for twelve
to change graph and mesh we don't want
to agree okay that would be a 12-1 type
yeah you know exactly um I mean I will
discuss the which house to make sure
that if we do that for audio what we
have there will not block anything I
understand we need to make sure we have
the design there but we don't need to
implement yeah definitely um okay so
what happens to did we already discuss
this part do you remember Stephen what
you're talking about what happens to
annotation yes I think she had another
name for that concept
well actually we already have mouths
annotation and things here right yeah
sorry um I wasn't fully engaged
I think it's a very obscure name for
what this is anyway well I mean so it
was imagined something that's general
and it's much more general than those
four well whatever
by the way Mouse sanitation is something
that works with a notation yeah but what
does it do what does the annotation do
nothing okay
and that's pretty yeah right I mean like
the visualization code internally will
occasionally wrap the annotation around
things when we want to carry things
through from you know the symbolic side
to the primitives as purpose is entirely
to be in an inert wrapper which can be
acted upon by other constructs right
which is the same thing as annotated
basically here yeah I mean the issue is
that there are some things that are
actually active here like the mouse one
and so on
oh I see no not really and it's just I
see that the mouse annotation is just
has this inside it and then when
something else sees that it does
something so in fact annotation in its
used here is consistent with what we're
talking about
by the way Mouse annotation doesn't even
wrap annotation I mean if you like if
you look at the first example for Mouse
annotation see the annotation is in the
first output but didn't Mouse
annotations in the second output if you
mouse over yes right but so what is the
deal with with the use of this and
rasterize which seems like very much the
same type of thing that we're trying to
do with annotated right so
rasterize if it sees a specifically
constructed annotation with you know
read with this region string then it
generates some additional information
about you know where that is pixel wise
how does it generate that well you have
to ask for it for manatee from rasterize
how rasterize that region's string it's
the secondary region specified by
annotation construct I didn't even know
that worked that's actually really
useful I could have used that a bunch of
times I didn't know we had that okay um
yeah there's an example in the rasterize
scope examples it does this okay but in
any case this use of annotation is
really very consistent with the
annotated with the use of of annotated
here and maybe we should just use
annotation for this rather than
annotated which we invented in order to
avoid annotation which we don't I don't
think we need to avoid tend to agree I
guess one of the things we discussed
before is that annotated element okay
for element it makes sense but
previously you had expression annotation
which then got translated into
annotation rules as long as annotation
doesn't get a whole object and then put
annotations on there annotation rules I
guess that's consistent right but
annotate is the thing that gets the
whole object right annotation is merely
showing the annotation that is there so
actually I think annotated annotation is
better than annotated so okay so then
annotation will get spruced up to become
the new annotation
annotation rules is an option for a
bigger you know object annotate is the
thing that comes from the outside and
gives an annotation to a thing from the
outside annotations
what does annotations do annotations
gives the same thing as annotation rules
because the right hand side of
annotation rules doesn't get it I think
you need all all the different what you
guys call tags and values I mean it
assume it gives it the whole thing
yes but annotation rules also has the
whole thing and the rules can be for a
whole object property list terms the
list of tags if I'm not mistaken rather
than the full annotation all right
oh really yes okay I see so I see I see
gives list of tags in the LHS a--'s of
the RHS of annotation rules is that
correct yes I wonder if it should be
called annotation names or something
you know it does encourage me that the
thing that we currently call annotation
we can use you know does exactly the
same thing I find that encouraging
I will do one more push but we should
all have a think about whether there's
an alternative name but otherwise I
think annotation is going to be the
winner
I'm happy with that um and then we try
and figure out how weighted becomes
something slightly different and we are
going to have to think about annotation
propagation and so on - it's fine
okay I think that's that's um that's it
for this meeting I think we are going
next to the visualization meeting and
people or on our livestream we're going
to change live streams and see you there
okay so I think let's go ahead next step
for this is implementation of these
things and then we'll come back for an
additional hopefully that will be fairly
fast and then let's come back for a
final review of this stuff most of that
already exists for audio just needs to
be renamed okay terrific do you want to
keep the annotation style that's yet
another object that Carlo has
implemented for things like audio plot
that would need to forth annotation yes
I think that's nice all right
is it annotation
Asian styles I think style following
plot style yep I see so if there is just
one annotation it would be I'm not sure
about that I'm not sure about the ass I
think that if it's going to refer to the
tag I think it should be called Styles
because plot style doesn't defy
default:return refer the tag okay that's
a good point well play with it okay all
right very nice and you guys should
think about the image case I bet you
other stuff is gonna work for that
alright this will make me so much
happier with respect to graphs when when
we get this nice uniform thing there so
it's fairly the name delete it bodice
you the design if so the design is not
bothering me
but it's not a problem with the design
it's July I realize it's the name okay
and I'm fine with right and you know
even the sanitation value equals I'm
even okay with that we're making
progress every developer and every
advanced user will be excited about that
all right okay well fine maybe when some
we lose some but yeah right okay look if
we can change this blasted property name
um good yeah I mean but we should
still keep thinking a little bit about
this word annotation to see if there's
something better um although I'm not
horrified by this all right see some of
you on the next meeting and I'll be
there in just a moment okay